hello everyone
thank you so much for being here for
tonight's architects of the brain
tonight is a fascinating panel i was so
thrilled to get this one because uh some
scientists uh their passions lie on the
bottom of the sea and some are focused
on space but we have four people here
today who are obsessed with that
beautiful space between your ears
so we've heard a lot about the brain in
headlines in recent months president
obama uh making one initiative to map
the human mind of course there's one
going on in europe as well where they
think if they have a decade and a
billion euro they might be able to
actually literally create a model of the
human brain in a computer but is this
wise is this even possible in any way
what are the benefits of trying and if
they are able to actually create a very
very smart machine and it reaches
self-consciousness will it send arnold
schwarzenegger to kill us
all valid questions for our panel so
let's just get to it we have so much to
talk about tonight so
help me welcome our four participants
tonight our first is a leading expert in
white matter everything that is not a
neuron in your brain he is a
developmental neurobiologist author of
the other brain please welcome douglas
fields
you got a whoop
we've got a fan club also joining us one
of the world's leading neuroscientists
investigating synapse structure and
function she's a professor in the
section of neurobiology at the center
for learning and memory at the
university at texas austin hook'em horns
please welcome christian harris
how come
our next participant traveled the
farthest he is a professor of cognitive
robotics at imperial college london he's
been focusing on the brain relationship
between cognition and consciousness for
about a decade now he also helped start
the existential risk institute at
cambridge join me in welcoming murray
shanahan
and our final participant is a computer
scientist and a philosopher and
editor-in-chief of minds and machines a
visiting associate professor of
philosophy at carnegie mellon please
welcome greg wheeler gregory
thank you so much for being here
and i will remind you we want this to be
a crackling conversation so i encouraged
much interruption and shouting over each
other and we're going to use the
narrative device of building a brain
tonight to take us through this next 90
minutes and to kind of understand where
we stand in the
you know development of an artificial
machine that has the power of the human
mind we want to know where who whether
they agree on whether it's possible
whether we should even try so each of
them are going to contribute to this so
let's start this out just by setting the
table with what a huge challenge just
this very idea is so
chris why don't you start us out what
are the challenges of doing what we're
talking about tonight
well one of the biggest challenges is
that we actually don't know where every
connection occurs in the brain
and in fact we know precious little
about where every connection occurs in
the brain and so one of the biggest
challenges is to um develop the tools to
be able to actually go in and map how
the brain is organized as a starting
point if you're going to build a brain
you actually have to know how it's put
together in the first place so i'd say
that's the first big challenge to
overcome
how little we know in terms of the
overall detailed structure of the brain
and we're going to get a chance to see
what that looks like
in its nano scale yeah you've got some
great animation to show us as well what
do you think doug what are the big
challenges
well
it's an enormous challenge to try and
understand the brain and uh make a model
of it you know the brain has always been
the most fascinating mystery i think for
mankind it's been called the most
complex structure in the universe and so
we've always tended to try and
understand it in terms of
of analogies to the most current
technology of the time and that could
have been mechanics or uh
hydraulics and today
we tend to think about the brain in
terms of an electrical computer
and it's humbling to realize that uh
the brain may not work like that at all
and um i'm i'm mindful of uh leonardo da
vinci he made meticulous precise
observations of anatomy and drew some of
the best anatomical drawings we have but
when it came to the brain he got it all
wrong these are the ventricles they
don't look like that at all and he's got
the eyeballs wired up to the ventricles
through the optic nerves now if you just
look at the tissue you would see it
doesn't look like that at all but he was
blinded his perception was blinded by
his preconceptions so he had this idea
about how the brain worked and then he
that blinded him to what he was actually
seeing later in life he he did make some
corrections and got a little bit more
accurate but i think
um that's a little bit humbling as we
begin tonight trying to think how to
well he wasn't the last scientist to be
wrong about it i mean it's it's just one
in a long chain but uh greg it's not
just anatomy and physiology it's
function
right it's what it actually does and how
it does it that's right i mean we're
principally interested in the brain
because of the things it does for us we
have beliefs we have desires we want to
do things in the world and the thought
is so we have mathematical theories of
decision making for instance how to make
good and rational decisions we go out
and look at see what people do
they don't do what the normative theory
often tells you to do so the question is
how do people make good decisions and as
we'll see through the discussion tonight
it seems that one of the ingredients
that we need are constraints we're going
to see how complicated the brain is
very shortly and one of the things
themes that we're going to return to is
that it seems necessary to constrain the
brain in order for it to do things that
are familiar to us so i think a
challenge is to see how far we can come
and understanding what some of these
physical constraints are uh to everyday
actions that we have and decisions that
we make
and murray your reaction when you hear
these ideas about mapping creating these
models from your discipline is it crazy
in your mind or you get excited by the
possibilities oh i think it's a very
exciting possibility because although i
think
it's probably is right to say that the
brain is not really like a computer but
nevertheless we can build computers that
are like brains which is a very
different kind of thing so we can use
computers as a tool for simulating
brains and trying to understand them
better and and it's that challenge that
really that really excites me okay well
let's start with the basics let's get a
little schooling on what exactly is
happening upstairs uh so kristin how
does a neuron work let's start there
what you're looking at here
is a neuron
it happens to be a pyramidal cell it's
one of probably several hundred
different types of neurons that are
found in your brain it's a cannot it's
considered a canonical cell so we often
refer to this type of cell when we're
looking at a neuron in the brain
and this is how it looked when
golgi and kahal and
nonson first began studying the brain
around about the turn of the last
centuries and
they began to really try to understand
how
neurons worked from images learning by
looking in fact
as how things were connected to each
other and what you see here
is the neuron cell body which is sort of
the engine for producing a lot of the
organ organelles and the proteins that
are going to be maintaining this vast
network of dendrites which receive
inputs from all over the brain and so
this one cell might receive as many as
20 30 000 synapses from different cells
in the brain in fact most of those are
from different cells we've actually
mapped axons passing through so now the
axon you see an axonal bouton and then
you see these little tiny protrusions
that come off the
surface of these dendrites they're
referred to as dendritic spines now the
way these neurons communicate with each
other is through
the axon
receiving enough input to actually fire
onto its neighbor and transmit across
something called the synapse a signal
that tells the the downstream cell
something happened upstream you need to
send this message on or not so there's a
lot of integration that goes on
so the synapse on one of these dendritic
spines now is shown to you at a much
higher scale you see a little bar down
there at the bottom that's 500
nanometers it's very tiny structures in
the brain and they're very compact
within the brain and you're viewing them
now as i view them in the electron
microscope and this has been you know a
big leap from going to from the light
microscope to electron microscope
because now we can actually watch
at the at the precise level
how the substructure of the axon and the
synapse and the spine and its neighbor
which my colleague to my left will spend
a bit of time talking about more the
glia interact to
refine and shape the communications that
occur through the synapses in your brain
and there are billions and billions and
billions of synapses in your brain so
we're going to show you a little movie
and we call it a cruise through this
neuropill and the neural pill is this
felt work structure of the dendrites and
their axons and their synapses and their
glia all
knitted together within this complex goo
that you see when you see a brain spill
out you know if
somebody's gotten shot in the head or
something like that right that complex
goo is this
network of synapses that are occurring
in your brain so what we've done in the
in the next uh sorry four-minute movie
clip is to allow you to see how
we as biologists
try to build a brain and try to in 3d
take a real brain this happens happens
to be a brain from a rat in which we've
done some experiments on and tried to
understand how these synapses change
their structure as the animal learns
something and when this is from the
hippocampus a brain region that we know
if you lose the hippocampus you will not
be able to get another new memory all
your old ones will be intact your new
ones will not happen so as we go through
the cruise um this neuropill you're
gonna see a central dendrite the
postsynaptic density in red is where
those synapses occur and um there'll be
some organelles a mitochondrion will
come up in purple
and we'll see some others too and the
axons will be in green the spines will
be in yellow and the synapses will come
up in sort of a copper color
and then we will have the structure that
we'll spend more time on later the
astroglia will come in to dance with the
rest of this neuropill
so we chose this volume to be a volume
that was sufficient to surround this
dendrite at the reach of its longest
spine so the first question one can ask
is gee you know we have this dendrite
has all these little spines sticking out
how many synapses can it make and of
those synapses of those axons that come
within reach of those spines what
fraction of them actually make a synapse
so now coming in to dance with this
dendrite are all the axons in that
little tiny volume of neural pill and
you're going to find out how small it is
in a moment that actually make a synapse
on that central dendrite
and
two of us joe spacek and i actually
manually traced every one of those
through 200 serial sections to identify
where the synapses occurred so coming to
join them for a moment here is another
third partner in the neuropil a critical
partner and this is the glia and they
interdigitate also as part of this nice
felt that is all communicating to make
your brain work at this moment at this
moment your brain is changing actually
in fact some of those synapses are going
away and some of them are getting bigger
because as a mature person you can't
support
all the synapses that you could possibly
have so now we've jumped into the way i
see this tissue when it comes off of the
electron microscope these are the
electron micrographs we're zooming in
and out and all of those structures are
structures that i traced with a computer
assisted program
and colorized them named them so there's
some ground truth for these guys who are
going to model the brain to know which
structures are next to each other and
how they interact with each other also
inside we have and now we're going to
get to see them in 3d we're zooming in
on that dendrite and you're going to see
just how complex the substructure of
these dendrites and their axons are to
support these synapses so the first
you're seeing now the dendrite and in
red are those synapses on those spines
we've
made this translucent so you can see
some of the 3d structure inside so the
challenge is not just how many
connections there are but how are they
supported by these structures that build
those synapses so there's three
mitochondria that are down the central
shaft of that dendrite and those little
white spheres represent the places where
protein synthesis was occurring at the
time that this tissue was fixed and made
they're called polyribosomes the blue
structures coming in are the
cytoskeleton that provides support and
the railroad along which all these
organelles and proteins get transported
and then now this network this
spider-like network of smooth
endoplasmic reticulum is what provides
support for
regulating ions like calcium critical
ions in the brain regulating them and
also allowing other membrane-bound
proteins to move up and down that
dendrite to the right place
so we saw a little bit of that
felt work neuropill we saw the dendrite
and its axons
now coming to join the dance are all the
other dendrites that surrounded that
same central dendrite that we thought
was so important right well these guys
are also competing for the axons
and those few axons that i showed you
before only synapse with that central
dendrite now the rest of these axons
were within reach but didn't make it
didn't make a synapse with the central
one but their synapsing with these other
dendrites that are in this volume
and so it's this kind of knowledge that
we need to have before we can really
have a realistic idea of exactly how
your brain is working
and
as we go through this i'm going to tell
you at the end here
that there are 500 synapses in this
volume 500.
this volume is the size of a single red
blood cell
it is less than 200 cubic microns so all
of that volume of brain that took us
years to reconstruct manually using a
computer and putting into this value
is
so tiny
that if we were going to do map the
entire human brain at that level we'd
have to repeat what i just showed you 8
trillion times
so this is why when bill asked me
what i see is the big challenge of
constructing a brain the big challenge
is giving me
the scientists the tools to do that kind
of level of analysis and work at
a much faster level and i think that one
of the grand challenges of the brain
initiative which is really what it was
built for was to both be able to marry
those of us who are looking at this
detail structure
to those who are looking at the detailed
function of each of these synapses
within the brain and i think it's a
really
wonderful time now for this brain
initiative to be happening because the
tools are getting better and better we
were talking earlier about the
differences between mapping that and
mapping the human genome or something
but and you and expound on the idea that
it's changing all the time it is a
moving target it's exactly trying to
sculpt something that is shape-shifting
it is it's absolutely shape-shifting so
we might get one human brain and you
know
a thousand of our lifetimes all working
on it together at this level with the
tools in hand but
your brain and your brain and your brain
are not all exactly the same and so
trying to figure out what the
statistical brain is so that you can say
well gee
you know bill's brain is normal and mine
is a little bit off
you know we're really going to have to
go
we're going to have to
not only get this kind of mapping and
this kind of level of knowledge about
one brain which is our current mission
we're going to have to figure out what
are the principles that can be
multiplied and thought of as
principles that apply to all brains and
that also then what
is a deviation from a normal principle
and i think this is another level of
really huge challenges deciding you know
where
where you draw the line as to something
has become ill and it needs fixing
versus you know that's a genius in the
making right let's uh this next bit of
animation helps put this in perspective
just the problem here so how many uh
put it in terms of computer power say
like laptop per neuron ratio how many
well so you know i think
we all kind of guess that a single one
of those brain cells probably has the
power of your whole laptop and there's
hundreds of billions of cells in the
brain and so i guess the first animation
is to give you a sense of what 100
billion
yeah we figured central park might just
start
uh so making room for all of that
computing power yeah in in a brain is
really also one of the challenges that
evolution has done that you know but
murray scientists haven't yet
chime in here on just just the the
technology that exists today in terms of
just showing us that you know how you go
from a cross section that's uh you know
in a dish
to animating that
yeah well
what we really want to do is to is to be
able to scale up the kind of thing that
kristen and her postdocs have
have have done and really speeded up
dramatically
so what you want the first thing that
you there's sort of several steps to
this the first thing that you want to to
do is you want to be able to make these
slices very very rapidly so you want to
be able to to to
automate the business of taking a little
uh a bit of neural tissue and
making uh the many many slices in an
automatic way so some people have been
working on machines that will do that
and we'll lay them out on a tape
then the next thing that you need to do
is you then need to
use your electron microscope to scan in
each of these little
little tiny slices so you get a picture
like the the kind that you you saw in
kristen's
video where you have one sort of
snapshot one slice through
through the brain but you've got to scan
millions and millions of those so you
really need to dramatically speed up
that process as well
and then then the next part that you
have to do is that you then have to do a
kind of reconstruction because then what
you've got is like a stack of plates
where each one of those plates is one
slice through this little
bit of tissue
and you if you can imagine you can
imagine this stack of plates if you've
got um
an axon which is passing through the
stack of plates when you look at one of
the plates one of these electron micro
microscopy images what you see is a
cross section so you might see a little
circle
in that in that top bit of the stack
and then you look at the next bit of the
stack down and then you'll see the same
kind of circle and maybe it'll shift it
a little bit further along and as you
can imagine each of these cross sections
is going to show you lots and lots of
little circles going down and somehow or
another so what kristen did
painstakingly was to to to uh you know
color each of those little circles in
order to figure out where that one axon
went down through all of that stack of
plates
but there's no way that you can do an
entire brain like that so that whole
process needs to be really really
dramatically speeded up and the only way
to do that is to is to automate the
process with with sophisticated computer
vision techniques greg you can speak to
this too because a lot of the modeling
is done using mathematical formulas that
were invented in the 1950s so not only
do we need much better computers we need
a new
algorithm system yes and even the
underlying mathematics i mean there's an
old joke in statistics departments that
you know the bell shaped curve this
gaussian distribution of error that it's
normally distributed
uh this and stationarity these are
things invented for undergraduates
we in real life errors aren't
necessarily distributed normally and
we're describing a process here time
series data that's not stationary it's
highly non-stationary so all the
tools that we're using most of them
anyway are built with these fundamental
assumptions but we're using them in an
exploratory fashion so we're we're
trying to bootstrap with these old tools
knowing that we
they're introducing biases we just don't
know how grand they are so this was the
the point that kristen was raising about
the techniques that we need uh so in
addition to the
computational uh machinery and
improvements in vision there's
fundamental advances we need to make
just in the underlying mathematics of
how to explain and measure processes of
this kind so i think the developments
and the advancements that we'll see will
have
impact well beyond uh the topic that
we're discussing here right
and so the neuron just the beginning as
we start to pull out a little bit now uh
the connectome so christian doug tell us
what's happening here this is sort of a
coloration as i understand of axonal
connections in the human brain i think
doug is maybe even more expert on on
this particular animation and well i
think the point of this animation is
that one of the goals is
mapping all the connections in the brain
that the brain works through networks
very complicated networks and um so
that's one of the main goals but it's an
immense problem in addition to the
technical problem
you have to be careful what you wish for
sometimes so let's say we do
get all the billion connections
can we understand it are you back where
you started i mean i have this we have
this problem in uh gene analysis we look
and others in the lab look at thousands
of genes changing at once and we can't
get our head around it well we have that
problem right and so
this
billion euro effort being led by henry
markham and europe is it taking these
complexities into account this is for
anybody can jump in on this
not yet not yet
and but i think that's the vision
and i think that's the vision also of
the brain initiative in this country and
maybe he's even an answer to the the
european and we could go for a few
billion in ourselves in this country
but i i think that we're not there yet
and i know that i mean henry's working
very hard to get and to get a sense of
how the columns of the brain of the
light microscopic level are
interconnected and so this is where the
idea of how do the
how does does the brain repeat itself so
that if if i were to do maybe only 2 000
of these and to sample it just properly
in the brain i could get some sense of
well maybe i don't have to do all 8
trillion reconstructions but that it
could be scaled down because there are
places that are similar and you start to
learn the principles and so i think
right now where the the
human brain project in europe stands is
to to try to get an idea of how the
columns of the brain at the uh the cells
and the columns of the brain repeat
themselves and whether or not the
anatomy and the function can be repeated
so that that would actually help to
guide those of us who are looking at the
synaptic level itself to guide us as to
well gee you know where should we go
next
to do this kind of painstaking work as
we even start to build
the new tools and i think you know some
of the vision of the brain initiative is
you know if you look at at the curve of
of of advancement you know it's kind of
a linear not a very steep slope
my colleague
miyan myeong-chun at the cavali was
telling us about this today that we're
really at a point if we can bring
more minds that are thinking from
engineering and from physics points of
view together if we can bring us all
together to really share our different
points of view that slope may start to
go more vertical and
and i think that
part of this effort
all across the world to understand the
principles from many different
viewpoints from physical points from
engineering viewpoints
that um the time is to really share not
not only to compete for you know new
resources to study our own little
favorite part of the brain so that's the
perspective from someone focused on
neurons uh
doug fields you focus on the other brain
as your book is so what was your
reaction when you heard about the idea
of a map
well i think it's a
fantastic idea a wonderful idea but my
first reaction was that well the map is
going to
look a lot like those early
nautical maps that uh
left out many of the left out many of
the continents and and had a lot of
detail on the home ports
because the map is leaving out half the
brain and i'll talk about that later
okay
what are glia give us a schooling well
we all know about neurons but only 15
percent of the cells in the brain are
neurons and you're looking now
just as kristin showed electron micro
micrograph looking into the brain this
is from mark ellisman's lab in uc san
diego and only 15 of the cells are
neurons you can see blood vessels and
the majority of cells are
cells that don't make electrical
impulses and these are called glia the
word means glue at this scale you can't
even see synapses
so if you're trying to understand
communication in the brain only through
connecting synapses i would say you're
overlooking
the obvious there has to be a lot of
other communication going on the brain
communication that may not be electrical
and it's probably not synaptic
what is it then
well
we can get into that
right here we show blood vessels i just
make the point that glia control blood
vessels your brain can't be on 100 all
the time
your brain takes 20 of the energy it's
only 5 of the mass so
local blood flow is turned on to
different regions of your brain and this
is how we can see the brain working in
these functional mris so as i'm sitting
here looking around the room different
parts of my brain are getting spurts of
blood to turn on those circuits the
glial cells are very much involved in
doing that in response to neuronal
activity and demand but let's go to the
next one then
the point being here's a neuron
and
with with all our fascination i love
neurons and i love synapses the synapses
are shown here on the dendritic spines
and if you counted the number of
synapses in the human cortex it would
take you 32 million years
counting one per second good project for
one of your
surly students i need many more than one
but the point i'd like to make here is
while we're focused on the neuron you
know the eye sees what the mind is
prepared to comprehend we're ignoring
what's in the background and the
textbook image of neurons always leaves
this black
and what's in the black are glial cells
and these are the cells that that
communicate without using electricity so
they've been kind of ignored we know
that it's apocryphal that we only use 10
of our brains we use all of it a lot of
times but part of that uh that old saw
is that einstein then used
12 or whatever it is but what is true is
that he did have a different brain he
did when marion diamond looked at his
brain to find the cellular basis for
genius she could find no difference in
the number of neurons or the size of the
neurons in the
cerebral cortex involved with
mathematical ability and imagination but
she found that he had more glial cells
than normal
so that kind of really focused attention
on what could glia be doing more recent
research has shown that uh his glial
cells were different he had a lot of
very large cells they were bigger they
were more complicated and these glial
cells called astrocytes
there are some that are unique
to humans
they're much different from uh rodents
uh they're 20 times larger volume
um and so when these cells were taken
from
humans and put into mice by uh
nedergaard and and uh goldman these mice
were
were
not geniuses but they were brilliant
they run through mazes much faster so
they have something involved so what the
glia do how do they communicate if they
don't have electricity here i have some
astrocytes in my lab and culture i've
put in a dye
into these cells that allows you to see
them communicating not with electricity
but by waves of calcium ions so this dye
fluoresces when calcium enters the cell
and what happens if there is a
malfunction in the glia how does that
manifest itself well before malfunction
maybe i should
before i talk about that maybe tell a
little bit about glia the kinds of glia
we talked about glia it's like
there there are many kinds of glia um
and they're into four major categories
glia communic glia called astrocytes um
and we'll show some of the background
they're nothing like neurons they
surround synapses they release
neurotransmitters they s they can
control synaptic transmission between
neurons they can pick up the signals
from neurons communicating its synapses
control that synapse communicate among
themselves by releasing
neurotransmitters sending messages
through glial networks not neural
networks and can control glia and other
parts of the brain
so those are
some of the things that astrocytes do
and it's another level of of function
and organ and control on the brain there
are many kinds of glia another kind of
glia are microglia microglia are
involved they're the immune cells of the
brain so in any kind of brain
repair glial cells called microglia are
involved but we've recently learned that
glial cells called these same cells in
your normal brain
are involved in unplugging synapses so
they make
and break these connections we're
talking about that's another difference
the the microglia move they're moving
like worms through garden soil in your
brain right now
sensing all these synapses and based on
the activity in those synapses plucking
some of them off and rewiring the brain
this is all all new new research another
kind of glial cells called an
oligodendrocyte it's a myelinating glial
cell people know about myelin it's the
electrical insulation wrapped around
axons
that allows for high speed information
processing it speeds impulse propagation
through axons 50 times so the difference
between a myelinated and an unmyelinated
axon would be like a race between
somebody walking a mile an hour and
somebody driving by 50 miles an hour
oligodendrocytes are why we have a brain
i think an evolutionary function
because oligodendrocytes developed only
with vertebrates
and when you think about it there's a
huge difference between
cognitive ability of worms and and and
slugs and snails and and people and dogs
and dinosaurs and fish that have
backbones the difference is they have
oligodendrocytes that allowed us to send
impulses long distances
these invertebrates have to have neurons
stashed wherever they need them like
next to the mouth if they're going to
move the mouth
but we were able and through evolution
we were able to form a brain because the
cells could come together and yet
communicate long distances
wow
but getting back to the
yeah exactly layman's term
but
getting back to the malady the
manifestation of bad glia
is that
is that like als or sure als and many of
the diseases we used to think of as
neuronal diseases als epilepsy
parkinson's all involve glia even
psychiatric illnesses uh depression
schizophrenia all involve glia in part
by regulating uh
synaptic transmission stephen hawking
als
originally thought to be involved
only with
motor neurons dying but it involves the
astrocytes as well as the
oligodendrocytes
so many
disorders hiv causes dementia and as
people are living longer with retroviral
drugs
they're suffering dementia
increasing uh numbers
hiv doesn't infect neurons and infects
glia only astrocytes and microglia
alzheimer's is associated with this
accumulation of beta amyloid microglia
eat beta amyloid so if they don't remove
it plaques can form and microglia
becomes senescent and can lead to
alzheimer's so i could go on and on with
the with this but uh i would also
i'll stop there okay well
i could go on
but
in the battle royale between glia and
neurons doug has the upper hand kristen
you have a chance to be
come back no no no i i must say that um
i'm also a
great studier and and lover of of
astroglia and
in fact uh our lab was one of the first
to show that not all synapses have
astroglia at them in the hippocampus in
particular but also in the cortex and it
turns out that those synapses that have
astroglid even just touching a part of
their dendritic spine those synapses
will be 50 percent bigger than a
neighbor that doesn't have them so
um this isn't a battle this is a
partnership symphony in fact i consider
i mean we all consider the synapse to be
now basically the tripartite synapse
there's the axon there's the the
postsynaptic partner and there's the
perisynaptic astroglia but what's what
doug has pointed out is it's now really
becoming clear that it's a quad partite
because the microglia is always there
deciding whether or not that synapse is
going to get to to stay on board so we
really
um
he's making really a beautiful point
that
if we were even to get every single
connection in the brain right we really
have to understand how it's functioning
and how it's functioning in relationship
to the other structures that are part of
the brain so doug if
let's build our let's go back to our our
world science festival brain project
we're building this um what would you do
you wouldn't think about it like a
computer well first yeah um
first of all
yeah and the brain's not a computer and
electrical computers are not digital
computers are not going to be
digital in a few years there'll be
they'll be super they'll be quantum
computers
so um
it's it's not rocket science it's brain
science so
let's begin with what the brain is the
brain is made of cells and what are
cells cells are bags of seawater so over
the course of evolution nature has come
up with these bizarre shapes neurons and
glia
coming together to make this brain
now the reason i put this out is make
this point is also as we're amazed at
how the brain works you know consider
the engineering problem that nature had
but the fact that
uh there are no wires there are no uh
hard drives there's no digital code we
there are no programs
this reality that the brain is made out
of bags of seawater a billion bags of
seawater put some constraints on how the
brain works
and may if you approach the brain with a
certain framework you may actually miss
how it works so for example neurons
axons don't send electrons down them
like electrons through copper wires
they
communicate by having pores that allow
dissolved salts to go in and out
potassium chloride goes out sodium goes
in and what happens when it gets down to
the synapse
how does it communicate
it squirts out bits of cytoplasm
the point is that you you have
rest leaked into my pocket
the point is that you
you you have these
physical constraints now this really
affects how the brain works so if i give
an example you go to the doctor he does
this knee-jerk
reflex
what's that about what's that's about
as we walk if we were to
stub our toe
we would have to swing our leg forward
in a split second to prevent us from
falling on our face
so let's design a circuit that does that
well the problem is i mean i wish it was
a laser beam or or wi-fi but it's not
it's a squirt gun
so what did nature do
nature took the neuron in your toe and
stretched it out until it was three feet
long and it goes up into your spinal
cord
absurd humongous neuron three feet long
the biggest cells in your body are
neurons once it gets to the neuron
spinal cord it squirts onto the motor
neuron another ginormous cell comes down
and does to contract the muscle
the reason
we have that is we have only enough time
for one synapse in that whole circuit
because this takes a long time and glia
clean up the mess so you can send
another synapse so we don't communicate
that megahertz axons don't communicate
at megahertz rates they communicate at
rates of only a few hundred a second
the point is
in order for the brain to work
there must be something more than just
connections
and there are there are things that
couple neurons together their brain
waves
oscillations in the brain of different
frequencies that couple neurons together
and make them fire even though they're
not connected something that we need to
consider if we're going to going to
build a brain and i would also say that
many of us believe that glia are
important in that coupling because glia
can encompass in the human brain
astrocytes two million synapses so they
can control local domains of synapses or
even populations of neurons so the glia
could be like a conductor in an
orchestra
making these groups work together and
these groups work together and this
would lead to higher level cognitive
function so um yeah
i like it
so murray you're a cognitive roboticist
and so if if doug's
doug's model brain involves water
balloons and squirt guns apparently
if we could do what people want to do
what kind of technology
do we need do you think well i'm
certainly not going to argue with doug
because he's got a water pistol
he's got a gun
um well
so to to to think about that let's um
let's uh take a look at the first video
but don't oh i was going to say don't
run it yet but we'll run it we'll run it
again so this is a really beautiful
video which shows the kind of thing that
we would like to be able to simulate on
a computer
and this video is is uh from misha
aaron's lab
at the howard hughes medical center and
and what it is is it's the brain
uh of the lava of a zebra fish and it's
showing the activity uh inside this uh
this this brain and this is in vivo so
this this lava fish is uh this zebrafish
is alive
and in fact develops perfectly normal
after this this this imaging
uh and the process this is a calcium
imaging uh process which is similar to
one that we heard earlier on so these uh
so so this is a transgenic zebra fish
not to be confused with a transgender
zebrafish that's something completely
different so um
so a transgenic a transgenic zebrafish
is is one that's been genetically
modified so that its neurons will uh
express this this
this dye
uh so that they fluoresce when they're
active when and it's to do with the
calcium chemistry that's going on so
when they're active then they will
fluoresce so you shine light on this
this unfortunately zebra fish lava are
are are transparent which makes life a
whole lot easier and you shine light on
the uh on the brain and it and and when
the neuron is active then then it
fluoresces and then you can image it
like this
um and uh and so what you can see is
these exquisitely beautiful uh firing
patterns going on in this in in the
brain this is somewhat speeded up but
you can in fact see the oscillations
that doug was talking about there there
are oscillations between the the
forebrain and the hind brain
that that show up when you start to
analyze what's what's going on there
so that's the kind of thing that we'd
like to be able to simulate on
on a computer so suppose so how would we
do it well so suppose that we were able
to construct a kind of map of the of the
of the connections by doing using the
kind of technology that we
were discussing uh earlier on and
suppose that we were also able to
um uh to understand how each individual
neuron functioned
um then uh then
sure the brain uh is not like a computer
but we can make a computer that's like
the brain so we can start to simulate
all of that we can start to simulate
exactly how these neurons behave and how
they communicate with each other so what
we're seeing
here is uh
it's just a thousand simulated neurons
and each of these
neurons you're similar simulating um the
mathematics uh involved in transmitting
the uh electrical spikes around that we
were talking about earlier on and you
can simulate that on the computer you
can simulate exactly what each neuron is
is doing as the
the potential in the membrane builds up
and then it sends out a spike so the
little red dots that you see flying
across
are when the neuron fires and sends out
a spike to all of the neurons that it's
connected to
of course this is just an animation and
it's an animation of the process that's
that's going on in inside the computer
and here you're just seeing uh seeing a
thousand uh neurons being simulated but
you can already see that there are
similar kinds of complex patterns that
you saw in the in the in the zebra fish
although we are talking about very
different temporal scales this is uh
this is just one second that you're
seeing here and and whereas you saw uh
many seconds uh speeded up in the uh in
the case of the zebrafish so we can do
all of that uh uh we can do all of that
kind of thing and really the the the the
enormous challenge uh for us in trying
to build a
uh a model of the brain one of the
enormous challenges is really scaling up
because as you've seen we need to do all
this kind of thing on a truly enormous
scale
and
scaling up to the human brain is a
really a
really
enormous challenge but if we wanted to
scale up to say first of all to to
the brain of say a mouse then maybe
that's something that's feasible within
uh within uh 10 10 years or so
then
we want to
what we want to do is build the kind of
thing that you've seen just now but very
very uh very very much
scaled up
and it's in the this idea of a brain in
a vat
is is
wrong headed right there's motion that
is necessary yes so i think so so
everything that we've seen so far is a
little bit like a brain in the vat we're
seeing
um disembodied simulations we saw a
disembodied simulation there and we saw
the brain of the uh of the zebrafish
lava uh we just saw the the brain
isolated from where it's not taken out
of the body i'm glad to say the
zebrafish's lava is still there but we
only saw the the brain
uh and we didn't see the body whereas
brains evolved in order to make bodies
move around in the world the body of the
animal move around in the world and
interact with the objects in in that
world uh in order to improve its chances
of survival and uh and reproduction and
that's really fundamentally what brains
are for so if we try and simulate uh
simulate the brain and try and
understand it and try and build models
of it
in this disembodied way i think that's
the wrong way to go so
from
the perspective of a computer scientist
and a roboticist what we need to do is
not just build a computer model of the
brain but we need to embody that
computer model so effectively that means
trying to build robots and make your
models control robots and make robots
move around in the world and interact
with things and we'll see an example of
that in the in the next video
uh which is due to uh tony prescott from
the university of sheffield
and some and colleagues from the from
the university of bristol
now this uh this robot which is called
shrewbot
now you can see that this robot which is
slightly scary um has got whiskers and
uh and it's uh the latest in a
generation of uh of a series of robots
that were produced by this group where
they were studying whiskers so they had
a kind of rat
bot before this
um and uh
they discovered some very interesting
things so they were interested in the
rat barrel cortex so that's a little bit
of the rats cortex which is to do with
processing the sensory information that
comes in from from whiskers
and what they really quite convincingly
showed was that you cannot understand a
bit of rat barrel cortex by studying it
in vitro studying it in isolation from
the signals that are coming in from
these actual whiskers and in the context
of a big sensory motor loop whereby the
the whiskers touch things and that uh
and then the sensory information comes
from the whiskers as they brush against
things and then that causes the rats to
change the way it's whisking so if it
touches something so if the rat is
whisking away like this and it touches
something is that a good impersonation
of wraps and it's and it touches
something on this side of its body then
it will change the way it's whisking on
that side of the body in order to try
and sense more accurately exactly what's
going on there and that's all part of
the big sensory motor circuit and in
order to really understand uh what the
all of those nerves what those neurons
are doing in a context like that or any
context you've really got to understand
that whole sensory motor loop so if
we're going to try and build computer
models of the brain then i think we
really need to uh to embody them in
robots right so we've got we started
with we need a lot bigger better
computers we got the bag of water idea
now we have animation showing that you
argue that it can't just sit there we
need all of this to come together
onto an actual object in motion that can
think and walk around new york city
yeah and it has to be really really big
yeah
that's it has to be that good because
otherwise it can't climb up the empire
state think about it so but greg
jump in on this i mean how far are we
just from as we add to our laundry list
of impossible tasks from just creating a
a robot that can walk like a human
well or like doug
i'm not sure about the pistol stubbing
his toe
uh we're making progress um a bit of
potted history before we cue the next
video um because it may tie together
some of the strands
i should maybe say some of my motivation
what really fascinates me about this
topic and others
are how well do our mathematical models
to our tools that we have to study a
phenomena like the mind or like the
brain how what do they fit with
the actual fact of the matter and this
rough interplay that's touched upon both
doug mentioned that maybe the computer
is not the right tool for
for uh modeling the mind if we were to
buy it at a computer store you'd send it
back right it's very noisy it's very
slow so maybe that might not be the
right model and likewise we saw earlier
about the complexity of these things so
with this background in mind
take a task that our robot might like to
the capability to walk yes in ai you
could look at the history of this of the
walking problem speech the main ai
problems reasoning language
understanding
and the first
chapter of this it was we're going to
throw as much computation at this
problem as we can it's deliberation
we're going to prove a solution to this
and this first
video which is only from 2007
uh instantiates this
design philosophy so this is the first
maiden walk of this robot
and uh
the idea is that this thing is
really deliberating
it's left and then it's correcting
itself and then right it's lurching
it's not at all how we
walk
and as you can see uh in the end
uh
he falls over
i might add that there were two other
videos we could we didn't get the
license for them so i have to describe
how to describe the trajectory of the
point i wanted to make with this the
first is that you can think of this as
an act of deliver deliberation it really
is emphasizing what's going the
cognitive
activity i'm going to put my left foot
forward and then i'm falling over where
do i need to put my right foot and so on
until
events catch up to him if you think
about how we walk it's more dance than
deliberation our hips sway our arms
swing it's a controlled fall yes we
pitch ourselves forward
but
but it's much constrained by our
physiology
and indeed the one of the videos i
wanted to show you is based on a patent
application from 1912 of a toy
this was
this is a in the video if you want to
look for it online it's from cornell's
lab it's a
martin
weiss's
work
and all it was is just a mechanical toy
that
affected walk walking purely by gravity
so you set this this toy on an incline
and the legs and the little arms move as
you would expect it's all there's no
motorized mechanisms at all it's all
gravity so the point we have this
computer and the first slide that we saw
there's first gra really deliberating
left right left right and then you see
this very elegant toy there's no
computation at all it's just done by the
physiology granted you need a need a
ramp for the thing to go down and to get
it started
and was this idea of uh that was filed
in london actually in 1912 based on
these toy designs so the most recent
robotics for the walking problem have
married these two things
right so yes we need to have um a
controller that's moving the legs and
and having an intention to walk but also
designing the robot itself to help it
along to put constraints on the problem
and that's the key insight that we've
learned throughout ai if we've learned
anything from ai is that
you can't throw more computation at
these problems they're too big
they're just vastly the search space of
trying to find the right solution to try
to find where to put the left foot god i
was successful where now do i put my
right foot
it's that's just not you're not going to
get very far as we saw in the video
what we need is to find constraints on a
problem could be night language
understanding it could be walking and
i've given a sketch of how that works
there's a gyroscope basically and we
we lean forward and we start swinging
our way and our legs are likely to land
more or less where they need to be to
keep us from falling over and we
accelerate by leaning forward yes
so
this
what i'm interested in i think is
necessary to make progress on this
problem
is to
find
constraints on these problems because
they're just too big to look through the
uh possible solution space
for the higher order functions that we
want whether it's
walking in this case or whether it's uh
language communicating having beliefs
desires and so on
so it has to
as we look at our continued science
project here uh it has a reason to walk
that's to have a reason to move right is
that yes so to tie this back in we're
adding more things to our robot so i
agree
uh that we need to have the
we need to have our mind embodied and
moving around in the environment but i
would also add that a robot has to do
something
it has to have a purpose
i rather like this one actually
that's a smart robot
but it needs to
uh it needs to interact with an
environment with have goals desires and
i might even add that if you if you're
thinking of us as a model it may need
other other robots uh similarly composed
one of the main cognitive capacities
that we have core cognitive capacities
is imitation we rip off stuff from one
another all the time social cues
behavioral cues
and base learning how motor functions is
children you can watch them struggling
with something on their own if a sibling
comes along that's mastered it you know
it accelerates rather quickly so
imitation is something that seems to be
fundamental to our
brain development and cognitive
development so we may need other robots
running around doing things as well
and
you specialize in reason you think about
these things and
talk about decision making in all of
this how that can be measured and
you know to catch a fly ball i
reference that at the top just the
amazing computations that go into
something like that
yeah so this is uh this is a nice
example on its own or i like it anyway i
and i i it might help as a simplifying
metaphor for some of the
challenges that we have at least this
theme that i'm pushing that we need some
way to deal with this complexity
so
take the task in this i'm taking this
example from uh gert giger insert at max
planck in berlin
there are two ideas that take the task
of catching a fly ball
yes
so one idea
is to uh this is uh uh dawkins has and
other psychologists have forwarded this
idea the idea is basically the player
calculates the trajectory of the ball so
it's going to know where the ball goes
and then runs to catch it
so this is dawkins when a man throws
a ball high in the air and catches it
again he behaves as if
he'd solved a set of differential
equations predicting the trajectory of
the ball
at some subconscious level
something functionally equivalent to the
mathematical calculation is going on
so this line of thought is embracing the
complexity of this problem what are we
doing
we're doing calculus we just don't know
it
uh
so what else what else could it be
well there's another uh
option hold on a minute before before
giving this slide because i want to just
describe it simply so the first is to
say that we are calculating we're doing
mathematics even subconsciously and
solving differential equations to catch
a ball that's what all baseball players
are doing
the other is uh something called the
gaze heuristic so this is the nice idea
here is that it simplifies the task
behaves
completely different than what i've just
described
in fact the cues that it uses not a
single variable that i wanted them to
put up actually the differential
equations to show you but they they
wouldn't they would they wouldn't do it
but you have to imagine if you haven't
if you haven't calculated a trajectory
you should take a look it's a little
nasty
none of the terms
that you would have in the equation are
used in the next rule that i'm going to
give you and it happens to turn out this
is what players actually use that are
measured they can't describe it
but they uh nevertheless follow this
pattern it's three rules and this one
works actually when the ball is already
aloft
first fix your gaze on the ball
two
start running
three
adjust your speed so that the gaze of
the ball your angle of gaze stays
constant
and if you do this you'll you'll
meet the uh meet the ball if you play
frisbee with a dog you'll notice that
they're not doing calculus often enough
you throw the frisbee they're not
running after they're running alongside
of it so they can catch the gaze
and then jump and catch the ball you see
this with fish you see this with other
animals trying to catch uh
prey or or a mate
it can be similar
um
but
the idea here is uh this thing can be
used deliberately of this is an
intuitive rule and it's something that
was used recently for an event here this
miracle on the hudson
right you remember this as the plane
took off uh from laguardia lost both of
its engines and the decision needed to
be made quickly
whether to return to laguardia to land
or do something more risky like land in
the hudson
and basically it was a virgin this gays
heuristic the co-pilot jeffrey skillies
spotted in the windshield the control
tower back at laguardia and noticed that
the tower was moving ever so slightly up
in the windshield which that is the
angle the gaze was changing and the
direction of the change was such that
they would make it so the decision was
made well you know what happened and
this is an interview afterwards this is
exactly what skilly said so it's not so
much a mathematical calculation
as visual in that when you fly an
airplane a point that you can't reach
will actually rise your windshield a
point that you are going to overfly will
descend in the windshield
now why do i raise this these examples
there are beautiful that i study i love
mathematical theories for decision
making for example
and they're very similar to the dawkins
approach about how one ought to reason
norms of reason follow from these things
and then you look to see how people are
actually doing this and it doesn't
resemble it at all so there's this
question of you know how do you bridge
this gap
and what we're hearing on the panel
tonight are clues clues that i as a
theoretician find tantalizing so for
instance i'm learning what uh forgetting
for instance wiping out information is
crucial to us we're bombarded with
information so we have mechanisms to
wipe out things so we can focus on uh
the bits that are most salient that are
most relevant to us making a good sound
decision um
and likewise these simple rules that i
just mentioned uh before are
exploiting
both cognitive capacities that we have
and also the interaction that we have
with the environment
you reminded me talking about this
i did a story actually last year at the
mayo clinic on pluripotent stem cell
research they actually dug a chunk of my
arm and grew cardiac tissue out of it
and at one point the doctor pulled out a
slide and it was uh they were growing
neurons in the same sort of way and he
said sometimes i look through my
microscope and i say i wonder what that
guy's thinking
do you think in the in the theoretical
philosophical terms when you're looking
at neurons or you're looking at glia at
that level do you do you try to make the
connections to figure out
how this
gives us this this sense of cognitive
awareness well a sense of wonder i mean
it's something we
delight in as scientists every day
cognitive awareness unconscious mind let
me ask you bill have you ever been to
moapa maryland no how do you know
whoa
you instantly knew
you didn't go down about heineken but
you know maybe
so this is the mysterious part of the
the brain the way that it works
unconsciously and has access to retrieve
information we seem to have a construct
of the universe you know where you've
been where you haven't been you didn't
run down a list of connections of all
the places you've been and check them
all off the way you would in a computer
so
that's very interesting
the other thing that in terms of sense
of wonder the point you made about the
body is very very good
um because a lot of what we take for
granted is being in the brain
actually is in the place of the body so
i'd like everyone in the audience to
imagine the last time you were terrified
for me it's stage fright
so
you know what did it feel like you know
heart is doing this and and your
respiration is going crazy in your
stomach and you have to go to the
bathroom and
and your throat is dry
for me it was when you got out that
water pistol yeah
and
the point is
what if
none of those things happened
what if i you were just as calm in the
same situation about to be mugged
would you still be afraid
can fear exist in the mind
and so i think the body is very
important to cognitive function and in
fact all of those things that i just
mentioned have nothing to do with the
brain really all the neurons are
scattered throughout the body it's the
sympathetic nervous system that controls
the heart and all these other things
right
um
murray let me ask you about the the
terminator matrix question
say this is possible we can
build a brain will it be conscious
will it
be self-aware well that's different from
the terminator matrix question so
there's there's two questions there so
can i do both of them do them okay so uh
so so uh okay let's
deal with the easier one first the
terminator question so
so i guess there are i guess there are
two motivations why we might be
interested in building uh simulations of
the of the brain one of course is the
scientific motivation that we want to
try and understand it and understand how
it works
and the idea really is that if
if we properly understand how it works
then we ought to be able to to simulate
it on our computer we ought to be able
to build
uh computer models of it moreover
if we build computer models and that
will help us to understand it so it sort
of goes uh goes both ways that's one
motivation and then the other motivation
is that uh is is a kind of ai motivation
artificial intelligence motivation which
is that may be
by building uh
models of the brain and understanding
better how the brain works then we're in
a we might be in a position to build
artifacts that exhibit
uh intelligence as we do or maybe even
intelligence as a rat does rats can do
pretty clever things and uh or dogs and
it might be quite handy to have robots
with the intelligence of uh a rat or a
dog which we don't have uh today
so there are those there are those two
motivations but so so if we really could
do this
uh
maybe you know it might be in uh 20
years time or 50 years time or even
suppose it's in 100 years time
100 years time is going to be within the
lifetime of my grandchildren you know i
mean i uh which i don't have any
grandchildren yet but you know
if i do then so you know i potentially
care about this even though it seems
like a long time away
so you know there's a there's a question
about what are the ramifications of that
for for for society and there is one
very
unpleasant scenario the kind of
terminator scenario which i i think uh
is actually worth uh taking seriously
although i actually i i loathe calling
it the terminator scenario
but um uh but it's worth taking
seriously and this is one i'll tell you
one reason it's worth taking it
seriously because if we can build um
something that has the intelligence and
cognitive capacities
of
a chimpanzee or a mouse
or
then a chimpanzee and then a human
then
then i think it's actually
inevitable that we'll be able to build
something or that that is uh that will
exceed a human being in its in its
cognitive capacities now it may sound
like science fiction and it is science
fiction but uh i think we need to
actually start asking these kinds of
questions now because we're talking
about things that
as i say may happen within our
grandchildren's
lifetimes
and
moreover the there's a certain argument
that goes that if you can build
something
an artifact that has human level uh
intelligence then it can start to work
on its own successors and you've got a
kind of speed up of self-improvement
because
if it can build something better than
that better thing we'll be better at
building better things and you get this
kind of uh you know uh intelligence
explosion that way
um and the uh the concern is that uh is
that how do you really control exactly
what
what the uh uh actions of this this
these things that you've built are it's
very difficult to uh to to work out how
we could really control uh um those
those kinds of artifacts
so i have to say that i used to just be
very dismissive of these kinds of uh uh
of these kinds of scenarios and these
kinds of worries
um especially when i was a young ai
researcher and you know i just wanted to
just build these things and um
but uh but but i i'm starting to take
them a lot more seriously as the
technology is is is improving so so that
was the one question can i answer the
other one as well so go ahead keep going
uh so but it's of course it's a
completely different question from the
question
uh of uh of consciousness because maybe
you can build something that
exhibits the behavior of a very smart uh
human being perhaps a psychopathic but
smart human being
and
and perhaps it's not going to be
conscious at all
certainly if we
certainly there are different kinds of
ways we might build it if we build it in
a way where we're emulating the way the
brain works then we've got extra reasons
for thinking that it that maybe it's
right to ascribe consciousness to it but
we might
we might depart from the way
biological brains work and build
something that's very alien
and then we might have less reason to
think that we could call it uh call it
conscious so there are separate kind of
questions you can have a you can have
something that behaves in a very clever
way
um but is not conscious at all it's not
that is to say it's not doesn't have any
feelings it doesn't experience the world
in the way we experience the world it's
not capable of suffering or of empathy
um so we can imagine uh all of that and
yet is still capable of uh you know of
um
doing all the things that arnold
schwarzenegger does in the films
i'm picturing a tv news executive as you
describe all of those
so so um
so then so that's a separate question
you know would these things be be
conscious so let's imagine that we build
a you know a perfect
uh simulation of a mouse say that's my
favorite example because it's a much
more feasible technologically feasible
example than a whole human brain a lot a
lot fewer neurons
so suppose that we build uh a perfect
simulation of the brain of a mouse and
we embody it in some kind of furry
fluffy robot so you'd want it to look
realistic and and and you wouldn't want
to kind of like you know a sort of hard
metallic body
um
and it behaved exactly uh exactly like a
mouse perhaps you had a particular you
know original exemplar mouse mickey and
it behaves exactly like mickey it shows
that it's learned the things that mickey
learned during mickey's lifetime and so
on
then then
if we think that we have some kind of
duty to the lab mouse to
prevent it from experiencing suffering
we don't want to torture the lab mouse
well then there's the question of you
know do we think about whether we it's
right to torture this thing that we've
made and it sounds ridiculous well of
course it's just an artifact that we've
constructed surely it's not capable of
experiencing pain so why should we care
about it in that way
but there's an argument which i find
very very powerful which is that imagine
that rather than doing this making this
uh
this
copy the simulation all at once imagine
that we did it one neuron at a time so
instead of building a computer
simulation we took one neuron at a time
and we replaced each neuron by an
electronic equivalent or a computer
little tiny computer that's simulating
what that neuron does and suppose one by
one we replaced all of the neurons in
the mouse's
brain until until eventually we've got
something that is completely uh computer
driven completely completely electronic
there's nothing
biological there anymore in terms of the
brain
well what happens to the consciousness
of that mouse what happens to its
capacity to experience pain
well it seems that there are only three
scenarios that you can that you can
really entertain right maybe it's
consciousness
uh you get to a certain point you know
you get to it's a neuron 125
376 and you replace that one and
consciousness goes right that's a you
know there's a kind of threshold
or
maybe
consciousness just disappears altogether
right away as soon as you get rid of the
the first neuron or maybe the
consciousness persists throughout
and uh to my mind that last scenario
seems to be the only you know one that
really really convinces me and uh and
that argument
for me seems like quite a quite a
persuasive argument for why we should uh
if we
imagine these these things not too far
in the future we really should take
seriously the idea that they would be uh
capable of consciousness and of
suffering greg what are your thoughts on
this duo do uh two remarks on risk one
is that the argument this is the
self-improving
ai and we should perhaps be worried
about this those arguments do uh depend
upon uh disembodied ai so i haven't seen
anything that uh
the the why do they depend on
disembodied all the arguments that i've
seen
are uh
assume disembodied ai they're not uh
they're not at all uh
considering power source they're not uh
how the thing would replicate itself
it's their their pure thought
experiments about
the kind of ai that we dismissed earlier
in the program
second thing about risk it's a more
general one and it's it's one i think
it's something that just applies to dual
use technology in general
it's a bit more permanentious in the
form of of
such as the technologies and sciences
that we're talking about here but also
just information technologies in general
is that we often will develop a science
a technique a method a technology
with a particular purpose in mind but it
can easily be reused for something else
good
ill
this is something that we've been
dealing with
for a very long time
one of the issues that maybe is a bit
more pointed and i don't want to raise
this just to dismiss it is in particular
the information uh
the techniques to deal with these large
data sets that we were talking about
earlier uh
the the this has this is the mother of
all duel use uh
issues and it's something we
we
need to be aware of uh in in moving
forward i think it's it's something to
to uh well i don't have concrete
thoughts about what one ought to do one
ought not to do with respect to this i'm
just mentioning these these dual use or
multiple uses of technology uh
are particularly uh uh
uh pernicious or couldn't be
particularly pernicious in this in this
domain because we're looking at so many
uh
areas of development
consciousness i will punt i don't think
we're anywhere close to uh
we just don't know enough to begin to
for me anyway to engage with with those
thought experiments
well thank you panel we uh we're going
to take questions now we've got a couple
microphones i think set up
and as people who have
pressing queries for these brilliant
folks
as you line up we're going to start with
a question from our
our audience in manila at the mind
museum there well this is great
uh
human brains are famously error prone so
if we were to build artificial brains
will we have to program these tendencies
to make mistakes
it reminds me of the of the the car
companies in in china stealing american
designs and actually engineering the
flaws in right
what do you think kristin
well i think it's in part a byproduct of
something that's very necessary that was
mentioned earlier and that is
that you you don't want to remember
everything that you're sensing
or you will
fill up and not be able to manage the
world so not only do you forget on a
very rapid basis
you have to you have to pick and choose
what's going to be remembered and some
of the things you don't get to choose
right so post-traumatic stress syndrome
will evolve if there's memories that are
traumatic it takes a long time to forget
them and unlearn them but there are many
things that just happen tonight that
you're not going to remember
and so the the errors are sometimes
simply a byproduct of something that the
brain has to do and that is be able to
also filter and to forget
and so what are you saying that the
recent research about sleep erasing like
wiping hard drives
a memory is is not a recording it has to
have a schema it has to have context oh
he's got a brush now
yeah i'm worried of these props
but think about it this is the next top
of brain science this is because
all our ideas about learning a memory go
back to pavlov coincident activation
sensory input
but making a synapse stronger is not a
memory
there's things like novelty
because memory is about the future
what's likely to be important and
something that's novel out of context
will be remembered so what happens
is if you remember
anything remember that
tonight it will be if you remember
anything from this it'll be because
tonight when you're asleep you'll be
playing the events during the day and
you'll associate it with emotions and
and information you already have in your
brain
uh to relate to that and and you're
going to throw out what's not important
most of it and you're going to then
associate those neurons aren't wired
together so what is it you know what was
novel how did you feel about it what was
the time what was the context what were
all the multiple senses that went into
this memory so our research recent
research has shown that also the old eye
our idea about how neurons work goes
back to neuron doctrine that that the
impulse goes into the dendrite and out
the axon well during slow wave sleep
the brain and the hippocampus undergoes
high frequency oscillations and the
neurons fire backwards
so
and in our lab has recently shown that
that erases memories now which is very
important as you mentioned so but the
point i'd like to make here is that
intrinsic activity activity that goes on
in the brain as opposed to sensory
evoked activity is very different
in it
it uh it behave then sensory evoked
activity and when we're
trying to understand how the brain works
the fact is we don't understand the
language of the brain is it frequency
code is it brain waves it's a little bit
of all these things so um i and my own
interest is in
exploring beyond the neuron doctrine
and trying to find new ways of
thinking about how the brain works okay
let's take some questions why don't we
start on this side what's your name
hey alex
uh i kind of want to touch up a little
bit into the um
the effort and the billion dollar
challenge to map the brain and touching
a little bit in with what you said about
constraints
do you feel that having that challenge
is kind of leading
the effort in
eight direction and putting a lot of
focus in just that one
direction versus if you didn't have that
challenge and you were forced to do it a
different way like looking for patterns
or any other kind of
way to solve this problem
destiny
for anybody i guess maybe kristen i i
can offer um some thoughts about that um
so despite the fact that there appears
to be a white paper that what's going to
happen is we're going to
map where every single activity occurs
in the brain and be able to have a brain
map of activity
implicit in all of that is way beyond
just the activity of individual neurons
it really is all the kinds of mapping
that we've talked about
and um while the amount of money that's
been put into it at this point is
certainly not enough to do all of what
we've been talking about
by focusing some of the
energy and the effort on trying to think
about well what should we prioritize and
how can we bring together different
fields to understand the brain people
who haven't been thinking about
developing tools to understand the brain
better i think there's going to be a lot
of synergy that comes out of it
rather than you know that there's a
threat to some particular field of not
being able to get enough resources to
keep going forward in the brain so i
think i really think that the the the
future is very bright
when you have a president and you have
you know the european community starting
to say look um we are starting to get to
some thresholds where we're going to be
able to learn something about the brain
if we can bring all of the great minds
together
to to look at new ways to investigate
the brain um and try to get this
trajectory off the slope that it's on
now and make it much faster
okay over here hi my name is samay thank
you for being here
and can you give us a little insight on
the manifestation of synesthesia and
your opinion on whether you think it's
a advantageous evolution of the human
mind
seeing music or yes seeing numbers as
colors yeah things of that sort
i don't know enough thoughts on that
well
there's a big question as to how
why we don't have synesthesia or it's
called the binding problem
you know the neurons that
look at the color that analyze the color
red on your shirt
are not the same neurons that handle
shape that handle motion so what keeps
the red on your shirt when you walk
around this room
so this is gets really into some
long standing mysteries in the brain as
to as to how
information that's being analyzed in
different parts of the brain gets put
together
into one object you know my arm moves
here why is it all perceived as part of
my body so that's a bit of synesthesia
is when that process goes wrong that
different senses don't
become
partitioned incorrectly
so
you know i don't have an answer but i
think that's that gets it the question
that we're talking about
young man
what's your name
callum hi ellen
okay um a few weeks ago i got this
subscription email from my it was either
ted or
nature magazine that um
it talked about this technique for
making trans um
brain tissue clear or something
i i i didn't exactly
have time to read it all
but
but i i was wondering if there was a way
like if you could just
individually
um
label
that like
every like the axons in the brain then
the
the glia cells in the brain or the then
the synapses and then somehow like do a
3d
scanning of that would that be is that
how you're approaching it or
that that is an approach that is being
used now to be able to
colorize different circuits
that you know something about the gene
that you've put into that circuit and to
be able to follow
the clarity aspect of it is that because
of all that myelin that's white and
gooey
it's very hard when you label something
to actually see where it went in the
whole brain
but if you can substitute that
the fat in your brain with something
that's clear
and still keep the neurons kind of
intact
and for them to still hold their die
then you can actually see them without
having to cut up the brain and do the
kinds of reconstructions you won't be
able to do the kinds of reconstructions
i showed you because clarity is a light
microscopy technique at this point in
time but one of the big questions that
actually is being pursued is to see
whether or not when you substitute the
fat in the brain with something that's
clear
and i can't remember the exact name of
the molecule they're using but it's
actually it substitutes for those that
are making it impossible for us to see
through the brain
to see whether or not if you section it
in the way i have for the electron
microscope we can actually get down to
the nanoscale analysis
and the answer is not in yet but boy are
you on target with the latest hottest
technique in neuroscience
thanks alan
yes sir
hi my name is tyler and i work in a
research laboratory but one thing that's
interested me is an analytical tradition
in philosophy of mind where you have
people like the functionalists on one
hand like daniel dennett arguing that
you don't need to understand the brain
to really understand the mind you can
build a mind out of any substance
whereas you have john searle on the
other hand who would argue that you need
to understand the brain mind identity as
sort of a single unit so given that we
don't really know where the unit of
information is currently whether it's
individual neurons or population codes
et cetera um
how how close do you think where we are
to resolving that sort of debate or of
how close you need to model the brain to
model the mind
that's yours yeah right um
yeah so um
uh
i mean it's interesting that you that
you raised this because uh i started out
um uh trying to do artificial
intelligence in a in a very very
different way by engineering ai from
scratch trying to build logic based
representations and explicit reasoning
mechanisms and so on
and uh and i uh kind of eventually felt
that this was going nowhere in terms of
building you know real kind of human
level little ai
so at that point i i turned to the one
exemplar we have of something that
really works which is not just my brain
but our brains uh you know biological
brains and because if we can understand
them
uh then then i think you know we're
really getting somewhere now that
doesn't necessarily so you know
obviously if we do understand how
uh biological brains produce cognition
and consciousness then we've taken great
strides to understanding cognition and
consciousness but that doesn't
necessarily mean that that's the only
way to do it though so maybe uh maybe
having uh you know achieved that if we
can achieve that one day and we do as
christian said earlier on abstract out
certain principles about
principles of how this works
then we might find that they're deep
principles that are analogous to the
physical principles of aerodynamics that
govern both natural flight and you know
and uh fixed wing aircraft and we can
come back and we could engineer
something in a completely different way
um so that would support that you know
maybe that's what what how things will
turn out and that would be honest that
supports i think a kind of broadly
functionalist way of
of of of looking at things if if that
turns out to be the case
i'm rather interested in the ancillary
questions that will likely emerge as we
make progress i'll give you an
historical analogy because we're not in
a position to identify what those would
be
take philosopher take descartes right in
his problem of skepticism really worried
about
having a system whereby i have a belief
that has enough justification that i can
uh justify the beliefs i have about the
external world
kogoto ergo sum yeah
and one of these
that's that problem for some is still
open the problem of skepticism but there
are other issues that i would
offer is very serious uh this predated
statistics
how to measure how to control error
how to know when we're wrong
uh and the worries that descartes was
articulating well the there's a subset
of questions that broke off and there's
now a science that's developed and we're
corralling these yes so my guess is that
these large big questions uh they're
interesting
very important but for me uh i like
these i'm really excited about these
these second order or the second level
questions of these kinds and i think
there's gonna be a lot of them that are
gonna be
be peeled off and and give us tremendous
insight into who we are
without perhaps resolving this
dispute between dennett and cyril
well thank you all i'm afraid that the
folks in line were out of time the clock
has been on zero we're about five
minutes over but please
for doug fields and kristen harris and
murray shanahan and greg wheeler give
them a big round of applause
it was uh humbling and thrilling to
share the stage with these folks and i
should mention before you leave if this
topic interests you further there is a
salon tomorrow at one o'clock all-star
in-depth conversation about this uh
whole initiative both here in the states
and in europe and you can find more
information on
worldsciencefestival.com thanks for
coming everybody we'll see you next time
thank you very much
you